MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So we continue our discussion
of nuclear physics.
And in this lecture, we talk
about the nuclear force.
Now, in the last lecture we saw
that nuclei are bound together,
and we were able
to calculate using
an empirical model the binding
energy of various nuclei.
Now, the question
remains, what is actually
binding those nuclei together?
If you remember, I mean, in
the first weeks and months
of this lecture, we looked and
discussed various interactions
between elementary particles.
We saw the electromagnetic
interactions,
the weak interaction, and
the strong interactions.
There was no discussion
of the nuclear interaction
or the nuclear force.
Now, what is this?
We have seen that
the strong force acts
between quarks and hadrons.
For example, we have
discussed at length
the pion, the pion,
which is made up of an up
quark and a down quark.
And those are held
together or bound together
via the strong force.
And we looked also at
the structure of a proton
and the structure of a neutron.
Now, the nuclear force is
the residual interaction
between the quarks localized
in different hadrons.
So the interactions between
protons with this up quark here
and the down quark here
in a different nucleon.
You can already
understand that it
will be difficult to
have a full understanding
of the nuclear force.
Why?
Because there's many
quarks involved,
and there's many
protons and neutrons
involved in this process.
So what we find later
that we can describe
this using a mean
field approach,
a mean field of forces between
the particles involved.
So what is the
experimental status?
Our understanding
of the nuclear force
is based on various kinds
of experimental information.
The first comes from
nucleon-nucleon (proton-proton,
neutron-neutron, and
proton-neutron) scattering
experiments.
And some of those
experiments have the benefit
of using spin-polarized
projectiles, for example
a polarized electron
being used to probe
the structure of a nucleus.
Nuclear binding energies,
we've seen those again,
and the precision
measurement of masses,
they give us insight, especially
useful for the light nuclei.
And the nuclear
structure information
such as energies, energy
levels, spin, parities,
magnetic and quadrupole
moments, again,
especially of the light nuclei.
And there's many more to
be named in more detail.
But conceptually, those
are the three kinds
of pieces of
information we have.
The experiment-- those
experimental results indicate
that the nuclear force depends
on the distance between
the interacting nucleons--
this is the radial part--
how far apart are
those nucleons?
And also, the spin and angular
momentum of the interacting
nucleon.
There seems to be a spin-orbit
and also a tensor part
when it comes to
the nuclear force.
It is also interesting to
note-- and we'll talk about this
more--
there doesn't seem
to be any indication
that the nuclear force depends
on the type of nucleon,
whether or not it's a proton or
a neutron in the interaction.
So that's charge independence.
So looking at the
radial part of this,
nuclear force is
short range, which
implies it vanishes
for distances longer
than about 2 femtometers.
So it basically vanishes
in this area here.
And the nuclear
force is strongly
repulsive for distances shorter
than about 0.5, in this area,
femtometers.
You can understand the
repulsiveness by the fact that
you cannot really push or press
an existing nucleon further
than its actual radius.
You cannot compress
them further.
This is also kind of apparent
in the liquid-drop model,
where we discussed, you
know, the volume term,
and the volume is not--
cannot be compressed further.
On the other hand, you saw that
there is short-range distance,
in fact, because we find this
linearity with the mass number
in the binding energies.
Right.
So here are the arguments.
The binding energies per nucleus
which is roughly constant,
indicates that the nucleons
and nuclei interact only
in their immediate neighbors.
Otherwise, it would have
an A squared term or an A
times A minus 1 term in there.
And then the measurement of
distances between the nuclei
at which nuclear
reactions start to occur,
those are in the order of
1 to 2 femtometers larger
than the corresponding radii.
The nuclear densities
which are only
slightly smaller
than the nucleon
densities, indicating
very dense packing.
So again, they are already
very densely packed.
You cannot push
them much further.
On the spin-orbit
force, here that's
an area where we could
go into much more detail.
But for this introductory
class, we don't.
We will not.
The scattering of spin-polarized
nucleons or other spin nuclei
particles allows
us to understand
that nuclear force
has a component which
depends on the spin
and the angular
momentum of the interaction.
Here's a fun fact.
So the charge independence
nuclear forces,
meaning that it doesn't
really-- the nuclear force
doesn't really depend
on whether or not
there's protons and neutrons.
And you can--
I could ask you, you know,
would you have expected this?
Would you have
expected that there
is a dependence on the charge?
And the answer
should have been no.
Because we just learned
that the nuclear force is
a remnant of the
strong interaction,
the strong interaction doesn't
know about electric charges.
So the answer needs to be yes.
The charge independence
of nuclear force
implies that electromagnetic
effects are eliminated
in this scattering, meaning
that when you measure aspects
of the nuclear force, you
have to be aware of the fact
that there is
electromagnetic interactions,
and you have to kind
of try to get them out.
And that can be done
by, for example,
comparing scatterings of
protons and protons, protons
and neutrons,
neutrons and neutrons.
If you do a comparison
carefully and subtract out
the electromagnetic
effect, then you'll
see that the force is indeed
independent of the charge.
We can make use of this.
So there's a lot of
information behind,
or experimental techniques
which can make use of the fact
that nuclear forces
are charge independent.
What you can, for example, do is
study so-called mirror nuclei.
Those are the ones
where basically
revert the N and the
Z for the same A.
So they're basically
mirrors of themselves
in terms of mirroring the
protons and the neutrons.
Examples are helium-3
and tritium, for example.
And those, then, allow you to
study in detail those effects.
So this heavy mirror nuclei
inherit heavy mirror nuclei,
the breaking effect--
the effect breaking
charge independence
of the nuclear force are strong,
and the similar does not hold.
Good.
One example where you can
study is if, for example,
one of those mirrors is
radioactive or unstable nuclei.
You can study the properties
of the unstable nuclei
by looking in detail at
the mirrored nucleus.
So that's one of the common
and interesting ways to study
radioactive nuclei, where you
cannot just simply take them,
excite them, and
study the properties.
They simply decay too
fast in some cases.
Here is a table where
you see this effect.
You see the comparison
between the nuclei,
this mirror nuclei here.
There's four pairs.
And you see that the binding
energy, the net binding
energy after removing
the Coulomb term,
is very much the same
between those groups,
those mirror groups of nuclei.
And this table here
or this diagram
shows you excitation energies
for two mirror nuclei.
And you see that the energy
levels are pretty much on par.
Without going into
any detail, they're
on par between those
two mirrored nuclei.